the first thing that you need to know is
that the internet is amazing and it's
changing every day once you've learned
how to get online yourselves you'll
start seeing web pages everywhere TV
shows have them schools Disney World
even the White House what's a web page
something Ducks walk on haha very funny
no it's the name of the different sites
you can look up on the Internet let's
start with the basics first there are
three important Services you can access
on the internet surfing the worldwide
web then there are news groups to share
information with people and then there's
email email I heard that's really neat
my cousin has a pen pound Sweden and
they write back and forth and it
transmits right away and doesn't cost
anything yeah you can even talk with
people all over the world on chat lines
don't they have chess games and stuff
like that too yep they got more stuff
than you can
[Music]
imagine